hey folks I'm Dave Ramsey national
best-selling author multiple times and
I'm the CEO of Ramsey solutions I'm here
with one of our Ramsey personalities
best-selling author twice over Chris
Hogan number one best-selling author
twice over
it's crazy times out there we're all
feeling the impact of kovat 19 right now
and not only on people's health but the
huge impact that it's had on the economy
the suppression it's not necessarily a
depression it's a separation of business
the shutdown has cost millions and
millions of people their jobs they're
filing for unemployment there's a lot of
uncertainty out there it's really scary
for a lot of your employees whether
they're currently still working for you
they're furloughed or maybe even they've
been laid off one thing we know is we're
gonna come out of this on the other side
we've been helping people with their
money for the last 30 years the
coronavirus has shone a light on an
existing problem even before coronavirus
Americans were up to their eyeballs in
debt spending more than they earned with
little to nothing saved and not putting
enough money away for retirement you
know the financial impact that the
coronavirus is being felt by everyone
and it's more than just a medical crisis
it's a real financial crisis emergencies
happen all the time in our lives
medical bills natural disasters company
cutbacks government shutdowns that all
can impact people's pay this time we
just all felt it at the same time
emergencies happen to people all the
time this is nothing new
people do need to be prepared but
preparation needs to be the new normal
one thing that's clear now more than
ever people need to be financially
prepared for the unexpected
in Chris one of the things we've learned
working with companies through our smart
dollar program our financial wellness
program is that employers really have a
lot of credibility with their employees
sometimes people don't think that like
we don't think our kids listen to us
you know as parents but employers really
do when they say something their
employees
really delicious they really do and you
have an excellent opportunity to step in
and to give your team members and
employees the help that they need you're
gonna have people at all times coming
into your office in different economic
times at different financial situations
and you can try to ask yourself how do I
help them
you can try to help with an immediate
need but in reality it's time to give
them the truth they need a plan to help
them change the way they're relating and
dealing with money consistency is a big
deal you can have a whole lot of
positive habits but when people are able
to apply those in their life time after
time that's where you'll start to see
the change happen and inside a smart
dollar that's exactly what we do we
guide them via video walk with them
through the process and not only teach
them about why it's important but
showing them how to do it this helps
people develop the second most important
thing which is control people or have
this sense of being out of control with
money they've never learned how to
handle it they know how to work hard and
to bring it in but at the end of the day
they don't know how to tell money how to
work for them now when we take that
situation we say they will listen to you
if you're consistent and you teach them
how to get control of the money it
changes everything and here's the
problem when I first started teaching
people about money thirty years ago I
started hearing people talk about saving
for college and we did some surveys and
there were some research done at the
time and we asked people how many of you
think it's important to save for your
kids college ninety six percent said you
need to save for your kids college you
know how many were actually doing it
four percent last year companies were
surveyed and ninety-two percent just
like the college savings issue said
financial wellness programs as an HR
benefit to help their employees is
important ninety two percent says it's
important how many you think actually
did a financial wellness program eight
percent last year when we were talking
to companies you know what they all said
next year
well next years here last year's next
year
next years now this is it we're here and
we're really have exposed to the need
for this with this coronavirus mess it
is crazy and there's some bad programs
out there under the heading of financial
wellness Chris and honestly since we
kind of started the financial wellness
movement it disgusts us it really does
and you have to be very very careful
because you can have something acting
like it's a helper but really it's a
thief charging your team and absorb an
amount of money with hidden fees and
things that truly will not help them so
hear me we have the opportunity for you
to be able to help your team members
with the program that's not going to
just talk about it Dave
we guide people well we show you what to
do I mean some of the programs out there
are basically payday lenders disguised
as financial wellness or paint your own
picture programs you'll pick your own
paint your own picture
there's a process you use to get out of
debt build wealth and move into
generosity it impacts your marriage and
we've taught millions of millions of
millions of people how to do this we own
financial wellness calm folks so all of
this comes under the heading of a
product we call smart dollar people need
a plan that will actually work and smart
dollar meets people right where they are
and it walks with them all the way
through to retirement and this is really
necessary especially in tough times like
these our digital solution teaches
employees how to handle their money so
they can stop living paycheck to
paycheck and we don't just teach them we
inspire them and we educate them through
great content and videos and we give
them our proven step-by-step plan we
know it works we know the average person
going through smart dollar pays off
$10,000 in debt and save sixty two
hundred dollars they put some in a
position to fund their 401k properly
yeah you're sick 401k program this
addresses it because we get people on a
budget we get them out of debt they're
working together with their spouse they
take advantage of that match you've been
trying to get them to do and it starts
to work then and we've got the world's
best budgeting app every dollar that's
plugged right into it and they get to
use that free of charge as well as part
of the program there is not a program on
the planet that has the kind of brand
recognition and the kind of success rate
transformation that smart dollar has we
have proven this over and over and over
again we really have and listen to me I
travel the country and speak I've been a
part of the company's rollout as they've
helped team members get connected and
when I talk to the executives as well as
the team members everyone is excited
about the opportunity people are hurting
and they want a real solution they want
something that's going to help them to
improve for not just for their sake but
for the sake of their family and you as
the exec has a great opportunity to not
just talk about helping your team but to
actually be about it and to show them
how so it's taught by video chris is one
of the teachers I'm one of the teachers
Rachael Cruz so our Ramsey personalities
that are all best-selling authors and
thought leaders in this space teach the
material for your team and we have these
big companies do it and then we get to
interact with the actual employees we
find some people that are absolutely
thankful they're grateful that their own
company provided this to them and they
show them how to get out of debt
and showed them how to have an emergency
fund four times such as this now I know
you all are hearing how incredible smart
dollar is and you're probably saying to
yourself this is a tough time Chris to
try to launch a new benefit and I get it
I understand what all the uncertainty
businesses are facing right now and we
are as well but listen to me we know
without a shadow of a doubt that you're
putting plans and strategies in place to
tackle the next 90 days while we all
figure out this transition well we want
to help you
preserve your team and avoid the high
cost of turnover we want your team to
make wise decisions right now not just
make choices in a place of panic people
need hope and they need a solid plan on
how to get to the other side of this
crisis well companies are telling us a
couple of different reasons I don't want
to do this right now
number one they say well we don't have
the money well you probably do have the
money that's the truth but there's also
a couple of things you can do in many
cases some of you have other options
available if you've got a 401k plan and
most of you do you've got plan assets
that are available under the ERISA
guidelines and some
you are sitting on enough plant assets
to just stroke a check we find lots and
lots of companies doing that matter of
fact last week we were sitting down with
a fortune 500 company that had enough
plant assets to pay for this for three
years and they were getting ready to
give everybody about $8 a piece back and
stood because you have to give it back
to them if you don't use it so this
helps them with their financial literacy
in the financial wellness space it's
really a strong benefit it's completely
paid for in plant assets the other thing
is if you've got wellness benefits under
the health and wellness side some of the
health and wellness plans like for
instance Cigna they've got a financial
wellness credit and your existing plan
through for instance somebody like Cigna
might actually just pay for this and so
there's a couple things there plus most
of you've just got the money you just
need to decide this is important and
right now it feels really important
because money is a raw nerve in America
right now with your employees it's a
place that you could actually bless your
team now the second reason that people
aren't doing this the companies aren't
doing this is actually more valid money
things there's a lot of ways to skin
that cat but there's a second one's more
valid I don't have time Dave our HR team
has stretched to the max with all this
stuff going on and we don't have we
don't have a bandwidth to address we're
just we're I mean we're stepping and
fetching over here baby we ain't got
time we got your back okay we have a
full team here at Ramsey and the
financial wellness team the smart dollar
team will do the entire stand up for you
they'll handle all the emails they'll
handle all the contacts they'll do the
work now you got the money and we got
the time and we'll take care of this
so no more excuses now what we do want
to do is we figured out around here if
we help enough people we don't have to
worry about money and so we want to set
up in these special stressful times
right now some offers we've never done
before with smart dollar and the first
one is for team members that you've had
to layoff that's exactly right
listen you've all been through tough
times and you've had to release some
people well listen we know you care
about team members and so what we want
to do is to provide you with an
opportunity to be able to reach out and
to help the
team members and employees that you've
had to layoff for furlough listen we
know this is hard and we want to help
you be able to help them so we want to
give them smart dollar for free through
the end of the year no strings attached
they need the help right now and we can
work with you to get it to them in the
next 24 to 48 hours it's all online it's
almost instantaneous we can stand it up
get in touch with us and we'll set it up
under your company name so you are the
one helping the people that you laid off
because that's how it's what's really
happening and then we'll provide the
backbone and caused us to all happen the
second thing we want to do is for your
current employees if you guys want to do
a trial a free trial to put this in
place and see how it feels see if it
connects the way we know it does we're
hoping to do that with you we want to
work with you we want to eliminate all
the barriers so you can get this out to
your employees right now so whether you
want to help your current team with a
free trial and put this whole wellness
program in place we'll stand it up we'll
even show you after the rete free trial
probably where you've got the money to
take care of it we've got all kinds of
pockets there that we can show you where
they are and you can help folks you had
to layoff or furlough and we'll pay for
that through the end of the year for
free for them this is this is a space
right now that the time has come I don't
know of anything you can think of that
more important for your team right now
that it other than their personal health
with the virus situation then their
wallet their pocketbook right now
they're scared they've been through a
time that they're angry they're confused
the future doesn't look as secure and
predictable and this is a time when we
as leaders for them can step in and
serve them from a leadership role you're
absolutely right and listen I know
you're busy but this is something you
can't afford not to do your team members
need the help and as they just laid out
you have an opportunity to be able to
help them in a couple of different ways
so what I don't want you to do is let's
not delay any further you've got that
opportunity you've got team members that
are counting on you that need you to
grab them by the hand and show them how
we're gonna walk them through the
process
that's helped over six million families
get out of debt be able to build wealth
and to give like they never have before
we're ready to help you and to help your
team all you have to do is go to smart
dollar comm slash hope so here's the
thing we're gonna get through this this
too shall pass this time next year we're
going to be having a completely
different conversation but there's a
moment in time here we have the
opportunity to step up as leaders and do
the right thing for our folks and we
know you're that kind of people because
the other kind of people don't watch
stuff like this so we're glad to be on
your team we're glad to have the
opportunity to come alongside you and
serve your overall team and we want to
make you guys the heroes to your team
this is the time to do it
America is gonna be fine we're be
alright but it's because of strong
leadership that that will allow us to
catch a vision again to walk out into
the light again and to move forward and
we can do this you got this we'll do it
together
thanks for listening